es war teilweise schwierige entscheidung
kitas und schulen zu schließen den
einzelhandel zum beispiel zu schließen
oder auch müssen dass verbote in den
pflegeeinrichtungen
wir haben uns als gesellschaft dabei
viel zugemutet
aber wir haben uns das zu gegründet um
uns zu schützen gegenseitig zu schützen
vor allem aber um die schwächsten in der
gesellschaft zwischen manche verkürzung
heute lassen es nicht schon normal
darstellen denn ich finde das wird uns
nicht denjenigen gerechten
pflegebedürftigen und ihren angehörigen
die recht schwere wochen hinter sich
haben gerade in zeiten der besuchsverbot
so richtig die entscheidung eben im märz
waren in der damaligen lage und
situation so richtig finde ich dann
immer auch zu sehen wie die situation im
märz war man kann ich im september im
märz mit dem wissen aus dem september
wir werden sie total die
wirtschaftlichen härten die da sind
gastronomie die reisebüros messebau
handwerk fehlen bereichen sie die herren
ließen für kinder für andere ich
verstehe dass da auch wusstest und da
manche
die frage ist was ist so stark dass das
das aus mit dieser aggressivität
ich kann sie nicht nur antworten ich
frag mich das und ich freue mich genauso
in welchem land die eigentlich lieber
werden